[TECHNO MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
Good afternoon, or good
morning, everyone.
Welcome to the second in our
week-long series highlighting
some of the fantastic
examples in our
Creative Sandbox gallery.
Today's episode will be around
YouTube, which we're very
excited about.
We've got two agencies on the
line, as well as a digital
production company.
And we'll go ahead and introduce
those in a moment.
I'm Brian Moroz.
I'm a Creative Lead
here at Google.
And to my left is Jeff.
JEFF POSNICK: Hi, everybody.
I'm Jeff Posnick from
the YouTube
Developer Relations team.
BRIAN MOROZ: So we're going to
be first speaking with Ogilvy
out of Paris.
Then we'll be talking to
Saatchi LA and Stopp.
Initially, we're going
to talk to Thomas out
of Paris right now.
And he has a beautiful view
out of his window of the
Eiffel Tower this evening,
if you can see that.
And we're going to talk about
a Perrier campaign.
So, why don't we go ahead
and run the video.
So we'll take a look at the
campaign and then we will go
live to Thomas and we'll have
a conversation about it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CLUB MUSIC PLAYING]
ART DIRECTOR: It started
with a simple truth--
the more people in a room, the
hotter the temperature.
So we decided to find a way to
bring this to life digitally.
The more hits a film gets, the
hotter its story gets.
By going into the club Perrier,
viewers will enter
into the hottest nightclub
ever seen.
Trust me.
We shot a close interior several
times, each take
becoming more crowded and
hotter than before.
CREATIVE DIRECTOR: And the
result is the first YouTube
video to evolve with the
number of viewers.
And to make sure it would go
viral, every viewer had to
invite all of their friends to
see the project in order to
advance to the next hotter
version of the video.
Thanks to Facebook, Twitter,
and email.
As the number of it rose, so did
the temperature as the new
stories were revealed.
And as the temperature soared,
so did the sexiness.
It got so hot, even the lamp
itself started to melt.
We turned an unusual, individual
experience into a
massive social project.
ART DIRECTOR: A unique club
deserves unique music, so we
created a one-of-a-kind
band to play there.
Babe Youth has raised a
five-title EP, including the
Le Club track, Break Me, which
has since been remixed by DJs
all over the world.
FEMALE SPEAKER: In less than
three weeks, 11.5 million
people transformed our
first video into
amazingly sexy content.
The experience has been hotly
discussed on TV and
thousands of blogs.
[MUSIC --
BABE YOUTH, "BREAK ME"]
Because people wanted to see
the next evolution of the
video, we got [? comples ?]
[? chair ?]
Tweets one per second at the
project's hottest peak,
becoming the first ad in France
ever Tweeted about
during the campaign.
CREATIVE DIRECTOR: I thought of
a new way of using YouTube,
and prove that Perrier is the
ultimate refreshment when
things turn hot.
You got everything?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Did you know
that two girls were kissing
each other in Version five?
CREATIVE DIRECTOR: No, but
that's a good idea.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
I feel overdressed now.
I feel like I'm very
inappropriately dressed for
the rest of this piece.
So, risque bordering on the edge
of appropriateness in a
very fun way.
Thomas, can you tell us
a little bit about--
just tell us about the campaign,
kind of where the
idea came from, the steps
you guys took.
And just give us a two minute
overview of how
that all went down.
THOMAS: Yeah, for sure.
Actually, of course it's
a bit provocative.
Maybe it's more provocative for
American people than for
French people, but
we're Perrier.
We've been in France for
over 20 years now.
And we've always played
provocative [? coats ?].
And what we've been--
actually, the brand has been at
the agency working with us
for a bit more than
20 years now.
And we've been really helping
them developing their presence
on the digital space for the
past four years now.
So, what we've tried to achieve
all the time with them
is to create a digital presence
that would be
relevant to the brand,
to [? Commis. ?]
And that's really where it
started from on this
execution, and on the previous
execution with them.
So, basically we are too
constrained on this.
When we started, we wanted to
create an innovative digital
experiment, and we wanted to be
true to the promise of the
brand, which is ultimate
refreshment
when things turn hot.
So, when you talk about ultimate
refreshment when
things turn hot, it can be read
as a physical benefit, of
course, but also as an
emotional benefit.
And when people get too close
to each other, things turn
hot, as well, on many
different levels.
And that's what we
wanted to show.
Or actually we made--
the starting point of the idea
was really one inside which
was the more people you got in
a room, the hotter it gets,
the hotter the temperature gets,
and that's when you need
a Perrier to refresh yourself.
So, we thought that
was really true.
That was [INAUDIBLE] when
you're in a club, but we
wanted to create that online.
And then we ended up thinking,
OK, what's the best way to
create that kind of
experiment online?
We will create the first
scenario of a club where the
video evolves with the
number of viewers.
And we quite quickly we found
that the best place to make
this apparent was YouTube,
because that's where our
target is going.
That's where basically we're
targeting 25- to 35- year-old
people, quite hedonist
and party guys.
So, that's where they are on
YouTube and that's where they
will share what they like.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So let me ask a question about
the idea generation process.
So, I think that the way that
you guys used that insight was
fascinating-- the more
people in the room,
the hotter it gets.
And the direction you took it
was funny, it was amusing, it
was titillating, and it was,
obviously, people were
interested in it.
So, given that you took that
idea, where did the idea of
changing the actual video
content depending on the
viewer number come from?
How did you guys come
up with that?
Is that something that you had
thought about before and
wanted to apply to this?
Did that come out of the
process of ideation?
Where did you guys
come to that?
THOMAS: That's something that
actually came out from the
agency itself.
Actually, we've been thinking
as much in terms of creative
execution, as in much of
innovative technology.
We wanted to have something
that's never been done before,
that people would
talk about it.
We wanted to have something
very social [INAUDIBLE]
that people want to share.
So, that's really an idea that
came from the agency at the
very beginning.
But, quite quickly, we also
had to involve all the
partners, which were of course
YouTube, the media agency,
some developers as well, because
we've been working
with [INAUDIBLE]
And we quickly had to all meet
together in a room to make
sure that we could make it
happen and find the best way
to make it happen.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And so to follow up with that,
what were the roadblocks you
ran into, if any?
And what were the
breakthroughs?
How did that process work when
you said, OK, we have this
idea, it's a pretty clear idea,
but on the technological
front, on the creative front,
what were the really difficult
areas, if any?
Or did it go fairly smoothly?
THOMAS: Actually, we've
had quite a short
time to develop that.
I think we did it in about
two months and a half.
So, it's been a very
rapid process.
That's why we got that everyone
at the same place at
the very beginning.
And we knew quite well what
we wanted to achieve.
So the main questions were,
how much can we custom our
channel on YouTube?
Because it was back last year,
and I know the customization
of channels on YouTube
have been
developing quite a lot since.
But we just wanted to make
sure that we could, for
example, host our six different
videos on YouTube
without having them viewed
by everyone.
So that was some basic questions
of, how can we
hosting at the same place but
not having everyone seeing the
video before?
And we had a true need.
That's why we chose
YouTube, as well.
We had [? a 20 to ?]
to make the YouTube channel
become a real club, actually.
So we wanted everyone to gather
in only one very single
place, which would
be that channel.
So, even in terms of media, we
didn't want to dilute our
media investment, or
create plenty of
banners that we were.
And we had to think of a clever
media plan to drive
everyone on this specific
channel.
So, that's why we work very
closely with YouTube and the
media agency.
Actually, in terms of media,
it was quite innovative as
well, because we nearly did
everything on YouTube.
And it really helped us with our
goal, which was to get as
many people as possible
on our channel.
And in the end, we get like 11
million people in our club, in
[? sweewix ?] and
[? our house. ?]
So, that's pretty cool.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah, that's a
lot of people in a club.
Very cool.
And Jeff, did you
have a comment?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
I actually did.
You mentioned one of the issues
that you faced was
making sure that viewers saw the
right video and that the
videos that were for the
different level of view count
weren't already exposed
in your channel.
Can you talk a little bit about
how you solved that
technical problem?
THOMAS: Actually, I'm not
a technical expert.
So maybe I won't go into more
details, but you'll be better
than me at that.
But basically what we did is
that we had only two trailers
were hosted on the classic
YouTube listing, I would say,
the one you arrived first.
And they were really like
drivers to your channel, and
then on the channel we had the
video seen in a background
layer, I would say--
I'm not sure you
would say that.
And we just unlocked them--
sorry, sorry about my French--
we just unlocked them depending
on the number of
viewers, we managed
to [? switch. ?]
BRIAN MOROZ: Right.
And how did you use other
media, social media, et
cetera, just to drive people?
Because that 11 million number
is an impressive number.
It's something a lot of people
would like to have on their
brand channel, or
on their pages.
What did you do besides,
obviously, clear just word of
mouth of this particularly
compelling campaign?
How did you guys drive
people there?
THOMAS: Actually, we tried to
add to the [? campaign ?] as
many elements of
share-ability.
For example, at the end of each
video we invited people
to share the video or the
channel or link their Facebook
or Twitter account.
And if they did so, they could
see in exclusivity the next
video before anyone else,
only one time.
So, there were some incentives
to have people--
to get people excited
about it.
But to be fairly honest, we
found it to be complicated to
find the best way to make people
go from Facebook to
YouTube and from YouTube
to Facebook.
And in the end, we also wanted
to increase our consumer
database on Facebook and it
didn't work so well, even the
number of people we've
had on YouTube.
The link between the two
were not as good as
we would have liked.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting.
OK.
And I think it's also
interesting, just to point out
what you said, that the way
that you guys incentivized
people to share the content
was give them access to
further content.
It's not that you were giving
them a product or a discount.
You were like, you're going to
get even more of this content,
meaning your content was
compelling enough that people
were willing to share it
to see more of it.
I think that's a really
interesting, really cool idea.
THOMAS: That was really the
idea of the campaign.
And when we were watching
other people commenting,
people were saying,
come on guys,
come and use the channel.
I want to see the next.
That's fun.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
I just wanted to throw out
something there that we
actually have a fairly new API
that I don't think was around
when you were developing this
campaign, so it's obviously
not something that you used.
But it is actually an analytics
API that exposes
YouTube analytics data, similar
to what you get
through the website.
And I know that your campaign
is very much driven by basic
view count analytics, but just
throw out there something
interesting that you
can now do that you
weren't able to do before--
is maybe take a look
at more detailed
breakdown of who is watching.
I don't think you necessarily
want to unlock the video only
if people in your target
demographic view it, because
that could be maybe a
little weird, maybe
a little not weird.
But it definitely gives you a
little bit more control to do
more fine-grain things than
just raw view count
information.
THOMAS: I think actually we got
a report of all viewers
done by Google afterwards.
But it was like three months
after, so we could have earned
money too directly during
the campaign.
And maybe we could have adjusted
our media investment
to be more precise towards
our target.
BRIAN MOROZ: But the numbers are
pretty good, regardless.
So, let me ask you a question
about who at the agency worked
on the project.
Because, of course, from agency
to agency, and even
just from project to project,
the people who make up the
teams that do this kind of
really fascinating work tend
to be different.
So, can you tell us a little bit
about who over at Ogilvy
kind of came together
to make this happen?
THOMAS: Yeah, for sure.
Basically at Ogilvy, we've got
a core team working on
Perrier, which is made of
Creative Executive Officer,
Chris Garbutt.
Our Managing Director,
[? Bernard ?]
[? DeFleurian ?]
is very much involved on the
brand, because he's been
working on it for 25
years from now.
And the account director.
And then we've got Frederic
Levron, who is Head of
Digital, who worked on it,
and a team of [? fall ?]
creatives, one Creative
Director, Thierry Chiumino.
And then three young
creatives, but very
brilliant--
Baptiste Clinet, Nicolas
Lautier, and Florian Bodet.
And one Digital Producer,
which is Hugo Diaz.
So that's the core team
of the agency.
And we really welcome the
conception and the
coordination of all the work.
We also worked with our TV
production, with Laure Bayle
for the production of all the
films, because we've been
shooting these six films in
three days in a cave in
Romania and it was minus five.
And there are plenty
of [? canister ?]
behind the scenes.
But they did an amazing
job on this as well.
So that was the core
team at the agency.
And we worked with a production
company outside
which is B-Reel London.
We had been working with B-Reel
New York before to
develop Perrier [? many ?]
times, seven and ten.
So they helped us to imagine the
digital development of the
custom channel.
And we worked very closely with
the YouTube engineers
just to answer basic questions,
because there are
plenty of questions raising--
concerning what we could do
and if we could achieve
exactly what we wanted
to achieve.
BRIAN MOROZ: Got it.
And so that's a couple of
interesting points I actually
would love to delve into
just for a moment.
One, it sounds like you had a
lot of creatives working on
this-- like every stage
of their career.
It sounded like you have people
that have been working
with Perrier for decades, and
you mentioned you have some
really young creatives
on that.
Was that a conscious
decision--
Let's get people in from all
across the board-- different
ages, experience levels?
Is that something you guys
did intentionally?
Did you just-- you just needed
the manpower, so
that's how it happened?
Why did you do such a broad
swath of experience and
backgrounds and so on?
THOMAS: I think for some very
specific reasons, we've got
some young creatives which are
very much in line with our
target audience, and which are
very much able to develop some
media-neutral creative ideas.
And I think basically that the
best to find the right
[? insight, ?]
that kind of [? leverage ?].
And these teams, we called them
the BNFs, who came up
with the idea of the more people
there are in a room,
the hotter it gets, and the
transformation of it on the
digital battle.
That's really the freshness
and youngness we
were looking for.
And after that, Perrier is a
brand we've had for a very,
very long time.
It has a very, very specific
tone of voice and brand DNA
which we wanted to
always preserve.
So that's why we've got
some more senior
people on top of it.
And of course, they're not
implied in the everyday stages
of the development, but they
were implied in the
conceptualization at the very
beginning and the association
of our client as well.
BRIAN MOROZ: Gotcha.
And that of course gives the
client, I think, a little bit
of confidence, as well hopefully
to say that, look,
this is a pretty crazy idea
but you trust us, right?
THOMAS: Yeah, for sure.
Actually, I must thank our
client as well, because he's
always been quite
bold with us.
He's been trusting
us quite a lot.
And [INAUDIBLE]
they've never been disappointed,
but they've got
some balls.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
And I have one more quick
question for you on something
you mentioned, which is that the
production values in this
were actually quite high.
You had film production
out there, you were
in a cave in Romania.
That's a lot of money spent and
a lot of time spent to do
some really high-level work
for YouTube, which can
sometimes be a challenge, I
think, for people to wrap
their heads around and brands
to wrap their heads around
that you could put some really
high-quality stuff on this and
it will draw attention.
Did you guys have to
fight for that?
Is that something that the
client kind of grasped?
And have you done
more of that?
Or have you done
it in the past?
Or was this your first
experience with producing
something really high-quality,
television quality for that--
THOMAS: Actually, it's an
everyday education of the
client, I would say, because
the challenge was really to
explain them that when you're
thinking digital, you should
not think, OK, low cost in
production, low cost in media,
and I'll do a great
[? best. ?]
And we're Perrier.
We've always had some very
high-quality executions, and
we didn't want to lower them
because we wanted to lower the
production costs.
So basically, the main thing
we had to make the client
understand is that when it comes
to digital, we need to
keep the same high level of
production, but maybe we can
play a bit differently with
the media amount to have a
repartition which is
a bit different.
And that's what we've been
doing already before with
[INAUDIBLE]
That's what we've done
on Le Club Perrier.
And that's what we've done as
well for our next production,
which will come next year.
I hope you like it.
But that's an education,
basically, we've been doing
with our client for
years and years.
And it comes to the manner,
and they understand the
notions of [? earn ?]
media as well, which you can get
on the digital, not on the
TV, basically.
So they're quite [? aware ?]
that now but we've been
fighting quite a lot before.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
Great.
So, just to wrap up, if you
were going to give one
recommendation to another
creative or another agency
that says--
I would love to do something of
this ilk, or something just
in this direction, this is
really inspiring to me-- what
would your single piece
of advice be to them?
THOMAS: I think basically, given
the process we've been
following, I think the
most important--
can I say two things?
BRIAN MOROZ: OK, two.
THOMAS: OK.
So the first one is, I think
when you are trying to develop
some innovative ideas online,
you need to keep it simple.
As long as the idea is based on
a true insight and can be
expressed in one sentence,
then to me, it means that
anyone would understand it and
everyone will want to join it.
And I think maybe sometimes
we like to over-think some
concepts, and end up with some
huge scenes which only huge
geeks can understand.
That doesn't work for me.
So that's the first point.
And the second point, to me, is
really, once you get your
idea, once you get that line and
you know more or less what
you want to achieve, don't wait
a minute to put everyone
the same place and make it go
together, because we can't as
alone the creative agency
develop everything.
We need the media, we need the
techniques, and we need to
gather everyone to make
the best of it.
And sometimes we tend to work
too much in separate places
before we gather, and I think
we are missing some stuff at
that point.
BRIAN MOROZ: Those are excellent
pieces of advice,
and thank you so much
for joining us.
THOMAS: Thank you very
much for inviting me.
BRIAN MOROZ: If you can stay
on the line, we will--
for a Q&A afterwards.
But at this point, let's go
ahead and switch over to
Saatchi LA and the digital
production company, Stopp.
Are you guys around?
[MULTIPLE VOICES]
We're here.
BRIAN MOROZ: There they are.
OK.
There's a whole gang over there,
so I'm going to go
ahead and-- well, first,
let's go ahead and run
what you guys did.
Let's take a look at the reel.
And then maybe we can just do a
quick around-the-table, and
you can introduce yourself and
your part that you played in
this particular creative.
So let's go ahead
and run that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: In 2012, Toyota
debuted the Prius C, a compact
hybrid built for young
adults looking to buy
their first new car.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
To let them build their own
Prius C, we transformed a
traditional online shopping
tool, an old-school car
configurator, into something
that speaks their language.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Users start building their Prius
C by choosing a color,
then choosing their technology,
and wheels, and seats.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
Prius C Configurator crossed
the line from a same-old,
washed-up site experience into
pure entertainment, ushering
in an era where online car
shopping doesn't have to suck.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MOROZ: All right.
So, a lot going on with this and
a lot of stuff to discuss.
I think it's really interesting,
and I personally
have a lot of questions.
But before we do that, can we
go ahead and, like you said,
let's go around the table and
maybe just start with Melissa
over at Saatchi LA.
MELISSA ECCLES: Hi, I'm
Melissa Eccles.
I'm the Associate Director of
Integrated, which just means
I'm a producer.
And I was the EP on the
project overseeing the
production.
TOMOS EVANS: Hi.
I'm Tom Evans.
I look after social media things
here at Saatchi LA.
The main kind of [INAUDIBLE]
is looking at how, where,
[INAUDIBLE] reach out to
[? isn't ?] working out, what's
the right platform to
engage people with, and why.
MEGAN BETTOR: Hi, I'm
Megan Bettor.
I'm an Integrated Producer,
meaning I work on video and
interactive-based content.
And I was the producer
on this project.
EREK VINLUAN: Hey guys.
I'm Erek Vinluan.
I'm a creative.
We had two creative teams
working on this, and I'm one
Creative Director and I'm one
of the Art Directors.
BRIAN MOROZ: And Zak?
ZACHARY RICHTER: Yeah.
This is Zachary Richter,
Creative Director at Stopp LA.
Basically played a role in
working with all of the film,
design, art direction, and kind
of just helping out in
the overall creative vision of
the actual production of the
experience.
BO GUSTAVSSON: Hey.
I'm Bo, Technical Director and
[? staff ?] for this project.
Basically, sitting next
to Zak on everything.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right,
you guys.
So, this is a big idea.
There is a lot going on in it.
There's lots of filming, there's
lots of technical
details, there's all
kinds of stuff I
would love to dig into.
But just to start off, if you
can maybe lead us through--
how did this idea get developed
within the agency?
With the client?
Just, what was that
process like?
MELISSA ECCLES: Well, it was a
little bit risky, actually.
It was something that was
very, very focused on a
specific target.
And we thought to ourselves,
how can we reinvent the
shopping process?
How can we reinvent the
experience that people are
having when they try
to buy a new car?
And so we wanted to approach
it from, OK, how does
everybody look into a car?
They go to the manufacturer's
website, they start to
investigate, and maybe if they
get far enough along in the
process, they decide that they
want to configure a car.
And we wanted to do this in a
way and on a platform where
our target already was.
And that platform was YouTube.
So we thought of, what is a
different way to do this
experience?
And the idea of a live-action
car configurator came up.
And we thought, well, wouldn't
it be fun to see this in a
different way?
So that's what we did.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So just an extension of that
question-- so it sounds like
the idea came early-- you pretty
much knew what you
wanted to do, but again,
there's so many
moving pieces here.
How exactly did you decide, at
both Stopp and at Saatchi LA,
how did you decide what
technologies you
were going to use?
How you were even going to
just piece this together
because there is a
lot to do here?
What was that process like?
Did that come early in
the ideation process?
Or did you say, let's come up
with the idea and we'll figure
this out two months from now?
When did the actual hard
technology bit
start coming in?
MELISSA ECCLES: It actually
started pretty early.
We knew we wanted to
partner with Stopp.
They were involved from pretty
much the beginning, as far as
the creative ideation
was concerned.
And so we said, what's the
best way to deliver this?
And how are we going to
innovate, which we decided to
do one of the first projects
really using interactive video
on the platform.
And then basically we partnered
with Stopp to figure
out how to execute that.
And Bo can talk about that
a little bit more.
BO GUSTAVSSON: Well, one of the
first things we realized
was when we were actually seeing
how many different
options you have for this car.
And you could go through this
Configurator basically back
and forth and selecting all
different colors and different
extra options.
We realized this was going to
be a lot of videos, and we
asked how we should piece these
together and how we
should shoot them was a pretty
big document that we were
working on, and many versions.
Every version of this document,
we realized, Oh, we
need 20 more videos, and Oh,
this option adds 70 new videos
and it just--
but we still have the same
amount of time to shoot it.
So we had to optimize how to
shoot and work really fast in
creating all those videos.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
And I kind of have a technical
question about how you managed
those separate sections
of videos.
Was it like one big video and
you'd have specific time codes
and say, jump here and then use
the API to stop playback?
Or did you have separate videos
for each of those
individual things?
BO GUSTAVSSON: Every single
option was shot separately, so
we knew we had the option
to use them separately.
And that was the option we
ended up with in the end.
So we had about 500 different
videos that we could piece
together in many variations.
So, the other option that he
talked about is like having--
rendering out all the different
options would've
been way more videos
than we planned on.
BRIAN MOROZ: Sure.
Yeah, but it was plenty to begin
with, it sounded like,
and plenty that you guys
ended up with, anyway.
So, my question for
Saatchi LA--
how did you guys put
together the team?
So, much like my question to
Thomas, how did you pick who
is going to work on this?
Who came together to actually
make this happen?
MEGAN BETTOR: Sure.
We can answer that together.
EREK VINLUAN: Yeah, so for the
Prius C launch, we had two
creative teams, a designer,
a [? live-wire ?]
creative director.
And we're the team that came up
with the TV, print, I-media
and this car configurator.
So we kind of worked
across all mediums.
So it's not like a specific team
was selected to work on
configurator.
It was everyone that
was assigned under
the umbrella launch.
MEGAN BETTOR: Yeah, I think it's
becoming a-- this project
was a true test of it, but it's
becoming pretty standard
for how we work at Saatchi LA
is as what's under my title
kind of indicated, can it
truly is integrated and
everyone works across
all platforms
based on the concept.
And we're lucky to have under
one roof a lot of the teams in
the same agency.
So the social team is highly
integrated from the beginning,
in terms of strategy, as is
UX and design, creative
production.
And then we work across those
platforms so that I--
it's not piecemeal, and it's
someone's not creating the
video and then passing it off
to developers, where we're
working on it all together,
which helps with this new
lesson is especially on
a project like this.
EREK VINLUAN: Yeah, and also
I'll add that we've kind of
come to a place where creatives
work across all
mediums now.
We don't work in silos here.
If you work on TV, you'll
work on a banner ad.
If you work on a banner ad,
you'll work on print.
BRIAN MOROZ: Wow.
OK, that's--
EREK VINLUAN: And it's all the
same problem-solving--
communicate the message
with words and art.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah,
that's great.
And I think that that's
something that is--
it's easy to say that everyone
should do that.
It's much harder to
actually do it.
So it sounds like you guys
actually did that, and that is
a big step.
And I think it makes things
maybe complicated, but it
leads to these very
nice integrated
kind of seamless concepts.
Let me ask you a question
on the client side.
How did they respond
to this when you
approached them with it?
Was it a total layup,
easy sell?
Were they concerned about
the complexity?
How did that go?
MEGAN BETTOR: I think we--
and Melissa can answer this
too-- but I think we tried to
keep it sounding more simple
than it really
turned out to be.
And I think we also learned
along the way how
complicated--
it just continued, as Bo kind of
mentioned too, it grew and
grew and grew.
The idea was very simple in its
essence, but the execution
of it became very complicated.
And they kind of had to come
on that ride with us.
But maybe they don't know all
the bits and pieces behind the
curtain as well.
MELISSA ECCLES: I think we're
really lucky, too.
We've got a longstanding 30-
year-plus relationship with
our client.
And they said, all right, if
this is what your consumer
insights are telling you, if
this is where your users are,
then we're willing to take
that risk with you.
And it paid off with the
time of engagement.
TOMOS EVANS: I think that was
the key, as well, is knowing
where the audience was and
understanding was that this
was a new product which
was reaching
out to a new audience.
And then we needed to do
something different to really
engage them and make them
understand what the product
was and why it was
the car for them.
BRIAN MOROZ: Gotcha.
Was there any one major
technical or YouTube-based
stumbling point that you
guys can point out?
Or was it just lots of little,
tiny stumbling points that you
just overcame bit by bit?
MEGAN BETTOR: I think Bo
can speak to this, too.
But I think, because it ended
up being so many videos that
had to work together, and that,
in essence, we wanted it
to feel like one extended
theatrical performance in one
video piece-- was about how to
make those transitions both in
how we shot it and then how we
put the videos together on
YouTube that was probably
the trickiest part for
seamlessness.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
And I think this is a piece of
feedback that we hear all the
time from developers who want
to have a seamless playlist
experience with different
videos, but you don't want the
buffering in between the end of
one video and the beginning
of the next video.
From looking and playing around
with the actual live
campaign, it seems like you
guys did a great job.
It seemed in general very
seamless, and things kind of
jumped smoothly, or maybe
not jumped smooth--
where it was smooth.
So obviously, you found
a workable solution.
So that was definitely cool.
BO GUSTAVSSON: Yeah, we
definitely found different
ways to use the [? Kronos ?]
player of the YouTube API in,
I think, probably the
best way possible.
But we were planning on a lot
of buffering, and a lot of
background loading, because it's
a experience, it takes a
lot of time to watch.
And therefore, we had a lot
of time to load in the
background.
But I think in the end, we have
a really solid build.
One nice little hiccup we found
was we also have a big
tool that's based on a Maps
application with an MPG
calculator, and everything
here is built in Flash.
And during the development time,
the Flash API for the
Maps part was kind of
dropped from Google.
So, there was a little issue
there, but we were able to
solve that at development.
It was a little scary
there for awhile.
BRIAN MOROZ: I'm going to
point at Jeff on that.
I have nothing to
do with that.
JEFF POSNICK: I will apologize
on behalf of your experience.
BO GUSTAVSSON: Thank you.
BRIAN MOROZ: So actually, while
we have Jeff here, I
just want to throw him at your
feet since he can run nowhere,
he's trapped in this
room with me.
If you wanted one or two
things on the YouTube
development side to make
some of your creative
ideas come to life--
this is a brilliant idea, it
was very complex, you guys
obviously figured out
all these pieces at
a very quick pace.
Has there been something that
could have made your life
easier or something down the
line that you would love to
see, what would that be?
MELISSA ECCLES: That's
a great question.
I think the share-ability factor
with this project and
the playlist.
That was the biggest challenge
that I saw, as far as the
metrics coming back.
We really wanted people to be
able to share it easily, and a
lot of people were feeling like
the sharable playlist
wasn't as seamless as
it could have been.
And I know we spoke about that a
little bit, but more options
for customizing that
share-ability and getting
those playlists to a place where
it can feel like one
experience versus multiple
video experiences.
JEFF POSNICK: And was the
specific issue because it was
a playlist of videos versus
sharing a single video?
And you found some difficulty
around that?
MELISSA ECCLES: Yeah, in order
to share your configured
vehicle, we couldn't really
share just one video with
their configuration.
We had to share a string
of videos that
went through to them.
And when people saw it
originally, they were a little
bit confused about what it is.
So, trying to find a way to do
that that's a little bit more
elegant in the next iteration of
the API would be something
that we'd be really
excited about.
JEFF POSNICK: That's
great feedback.
I'll ask if they can pass that
on to the relevant folks
internally.
BRIAN MOROZ: Definitely.
And let me ask you guys, because
there's a lot of folks
on the Hangout right now from
two different groups, right.
And I'm sure there's more
people internally.
It sounds like there was
just a whole lot of
cooks in the kitchen.
How did you guys manage, and
especially given that it is
not siloed, everyone does kind
of work across all these
mediums, et cetera--
how do you manage having
so many brains on
one enormous idea?
MELISSA ECCLES: There's
war rooms.
TOMOS EVANS: A lot
of meetings.
MELISSA ECCLES: A
lot of meetings.
MEGAN BETTOR: And a lot of
deferring to our expert
partners at Stopp.
That's why we bring in
partners like them--
to help take the lead and help
direct us, too, especially
when things start to move really
quickly and with a lot
of factors.
ZACHARY RICHTER: Yeah, I think
to Melissa's point earlier
when she was talking about
essentially have everything--
just bring us in early on a
project, having us all sort of
formulate these, bringing
everyone's expertise to the
table early and having these
workshops in the beginning was
so important.
We definitely did not feel like
a vendor on this project,
and we really felt like a
partner and that was key to
making this whole thing go
as smoothly as possible.
There were a lot of hiccups
along the way, but really just
liked when she was saying,
[? Boo ?] made this document
early on that showed how many
videos we actually did making
these giant trees, figuring all
these things out visually,
and having everyone
together was key.
MELISSA ECCLES: Yeah,
one team one dream.
It sounds cheesy,
but it's true.
And everybody really believed
that we were doing something
innovative and something
groundbreaking.
So it's easy for people to
collaborate when they're
really excited about the idea
they're collaborating on.
So it was a dream project
in that respect.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And it sounds like you had quite
the backing from your
client, too, which that always
helps as well, to say, no,
we've got the green light on
this as long as we can pull it
all together.
MELISSA ECCLES: Yeah,
absolutely.
JEFF POSNICK: Now might be a
good time to mention that we
are taking questions from
the general viewing
audience right now.
We have a Google Moderator
link that should be
somewhere below me.
And feel free to add whatever
questions that you might have
after watching what we've been
talking about to supplement
the types of questions
we're asking.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah, and so just
to ask you guys one further
question, I'm going to ask you
the same question I asked
Thomas which is, if you had one,
or in his case two, one
or two insights that if that you
were going to share with
another person who said, I'm
thinking about doing something
that's kind of similar in this
vein, it's a big idea, it's
really complicated, lots of
video, what would be the one
or two things you would say,
this is absolutely necessary
and we learned this
in this process?
TOMOS EVANS: I think one
of the keys was really
understanding the audience and
being able to tie that back to
the product, because if we
were doing this for a
different product, this wouldn't
have been the right
place to do it.
So having that and really being
clear from Day One on
that really, really
helps a lot.
BRIAN MOROZ: So know
your audience.
That's something
that honestly--
and that's actually a very
good insight and one that
maybe gets missed sometimes when
people get very excited
about a particular technology.
Because it's easy to say, we
could do this really flashy
thing, but having that focus
on the audience is a really
great piece of advice to people
that are actually
thinking of developing
something like this.
So, before we cut over to see if
we've got some questions on
the moderator tool, any
last comments or
questions from you guys--
Saatchi LA, or Stopp?
Either just in general on the
project, the experience, or
any final questions or requests
of Jeff and YouTube?
ZACHARY RICHTER: I would say--
sorry, I was going to say one
thing that we definitely
learned and if we could do it
all over again would be to
have all these technologies
solidified upfront.
We worked at such a fast pace
that to have things changing
and moving along the way, that
definitely creates hiccups and
you spend more time working on
these things that could have
been solidified instead of
working on the actual
creative, and I think that
definitely hindered part of
it, hindered a little bit of
the seamlessness that we
discussed earlier.
But overall, I think everything
went pretty
smoothly, but again, if we could
just have everything
very, very solidified,
it would've helped.
MELISSA ECCLES: We'd love to
borrow your engineers so we
could all work in-house
together.
That would be awesome.
ZACHARY RICHTER: Agreed.
BRIAN MOROZ: Feel like
going to LA?
The weather's getting really bad
here in New York, so it's
a good time to make an offer.
MEGAN BETTOR: It's beautiful
in LA, today.
JEFF POSNICK: That does
sound really tempting.
I also wanted to point out that
this is absolutely not
the only opportunity that folks
have to ask questions of
me, whether you're one of the
agencies that we've worked
with, or you're just an average
YouTube developer, the
Developer Relations team tries
to do our best to answer all
the questions that come in
related to the YouTube APIs.
And our actual best way of
reaching us right now is
posting on Stack Overflow--
which is a website
for developers--
and tagging your question
with YouTube-API.
And I and my teammates look at
those all the time, and we're
always happy to help folks.
BRIAN MOROZ: So, we actually do
have a couple of questions
that have come in.
So I will go ahead and pose
these to everyone on the call.
And this one-- is Thomas
still with us?
THOMAS: Yes, I'm still there.
BRIAN MOROZ: Thank you, sir.
So was Le Club Perrier
embeddable?
How did it perform in mobile
devices outside of the regular
YouTube channel experience?
So was that embeddable?
Was that something that you
could move to other devices?
Or was that something
that lived on the
brand channel only?
THOMAS: Actually, that's a very
good question and that's
one of the difficulties we've
had with the custom channel of
YouTube, because we would have
liked, ideally, to be able to
give people the same experiment
online, on the
[? device, ?]
sorry.
And we found it quite difficult
to get an adaptable
custom channel, so what
we did is we were
working with [? APO ?]
[? Ziad ?]
and we developed the same kind
of experiment directly on
[? miad, ?] but we couldn't do
it with YouTube mobile app.
So if that's something to
work on guys, that's it.
Very good question.
BRIAN MOROZ: On Saatchi
LA, same thing--
any mobile work with
the campaign?
Or was it the same situation
as for Thomas?
MEGAN BETTOR: Same situation.
It was a--
BRIAN MOROZ: I figured.
OK, so we have another list
of items to work on?
JEFF POSNICK: We do.
I'll point out that we actually,
back in July at our
Google I/O conference, announced
something that is
kind of relevant to the mobile
space, and that's an Android
player library that will now
allow for native YouTube
playback within Android
applications.
And it makes it a little bit
easier to do that whole
embedded playback scenario if
you already have a mobile app.
So that's not something that's
quite public yet, so obviously
not something you
could have used.
But we're working really hard
on making that publicly
available and releasing it.
So I think, in that sense,
things might get a little bit
better soon.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
And that question, by the
way, was from Tim.
Another question from Peter in
Vancouver, which is very
similar and I think we just
heard the answer there was,
how important was mobile
participation to
the campaign success?
And it sounds like these were
just not mobile-focused
campaigns, in this case,
but would've been
great if they were.
THOMAS: Unfortunate.
BRIAN MOROZ: If I'm
not putting words
into people's mouths.
Another question that just
came through, which was
actually quite interesting,
from Alex in Los Angeles.
Besides sharing the configured
car to social networks, what
other CTAs were encouraged?
Were you able to tie a
configuration down to the
actual sale of a car?
How did this integrate across
other media and channels?
So what were the actions that
you guys were really measuring
and wanting to see?
And how tightly was it connected
to actual dollar
sale ROI, et cetera?
MEGAN BETTOR: For us this
was a bit more,
it was a new vehicle.
And for our first-time car
buyers, it was more about,
meet the Prius, an initial
introduction to the vehicle,
and getting to know it and
all of the elements
available to you.
So for us, it was really about
engagement and time spent,
which was a shocking metric
for us, actually.
We had people spending about 22
minutes in the experience.
BRIAN MOROZ: Whoa!
MEGAN BETTOR: Yeah.
Crazy, right?
We've rechecked the numbers
so many times.
That they were spending that
much time going through the
Configurator, building their
version of the Prius C, and
entering it again-- so to us
that was the primary element
for success.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
ZACHARY RICHTER: Yeah.
I was going to say, due to the
time that we actually had to
launch this, we did have the
idea to tie this experience
directly in with something that
was going to deliver on
toyota.com.
But it actually just kind
of ended up being quite
complicated, and it was more
important that they were just
actually able to configure their
car and share it than to
actually have it on toyota.com,
to see it on
toyota.com.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
22 minutes, that
blows my mind.
That's like a sitcom without
the ads, essentially.
So when you TiVo a sitcom.
That is crazy.
So that's great.
And Saatchi LA, Stopp, Thomas
with Ogilvy, any final
questions or comments before
we wrap up for today?
MEGAN BETTOR: That was really--
it was a fun project,
and it's really exciting to get
to talk about it and share
it with everybody.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
Yeah, these were both just
beautiful and amazing pieces
of creative and technology.
And both so totally different
and totally amazing.
So it's been a real pleasure for
us to be able to talk with
you and for everyone who's
on the Hangout.
So thank you guys, everyone,
so much for
being here and sharing.
This has been recorded, so we
will be releasing it sometime
in the next several
days, I believe.
And that information will go out
in the same channels that
the information for
this Hangout went.
And I'll just wrap by saying,
thank you so much to everyone
here today and for those of you
that are watching at home
or at your offices.
If you'd like to join tomorrow,
tomorrow we're going
to be discussing some
DoubleClick Rich Media uses
that we thought were
pretty interesting.
And you can find these fantastic
examples that we
talked about today, as well
as many others at
creativesandbox.com.
So go check that out if you'd
like to see some further work.
So with that, thanks again so
much to everyone, and we
really appreciate it.
[MULTIPLE SPEAKERS]
Thanks.
Thank you.
BRIAN MOROZ: Bye, everybody.
JEFF POSNICK: Bye, everybody.
MELISSA ECCLES: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]